chevrier bonjour je voulais centrer
pardon philippe chevrier bienvenue au
bistrot du théâtre à
montigny-le-bretonneux première invitée
du café politique pour cette cette
reprise après la trêve des élections
vous êtes le responsable départemental
du front national vous êtes nouvel élu
au sein du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france là dans l'opposition
vous avez vous siégez aussi dans
l'opposition conseil municipal mais à
rambouillet c'est ainsi que d'opposition
voilà à chaque fois dans l'opposition
comment se passent ces premiers pas à la
région aux côtés de vallerand de
saint-just côté honnêtement on n'a pas
commencé de cession que c'est un peu
prématuré pour en parler mais bon on est
tous contents de se retrouver ensemble
lorsqu'il a vu un changement il n'avait
pas d'élus du front national auparavant
lorsque vous vous êtes retrouvé à dans
l'est dans l'hémicycle il ya eu en fait
été un sentiment particulier sur la
première séance d'installation
ouais un sentiment de fierté retrouvée
là on y était avant enfin on n'était pas
la mandature de dames et sur celle de la
semaine précédente mais celle celle
d'avant on était donc c'était agréable
de s'y retrouver quoi donc de retrouver
ses marques
vous avez déclaré à l'issue du résultat
des élections être déçu malgré tout du
score en ile-de-france de votre
formation politique vous avez exagéré
c'est passé tout près du premier tour
vous avez ces résultats on était en
dessous des espérances puisque bondée
les sondages nous avait mis à 21 et puis
on s'est retrouvé à dix huit donc
effectivement c'est un petit choc quoi
d'aujourd'hui la progression n'était pas
aussi forte que la progression nationale
du front national donc par contre au
deuxième tour on n'a pas trop mal
résisté par rapport à ce qui s'était
passé au départemental
donc voilà donc je suis à nouveau
rasséréné son cours de cette émission on
parlera comme c'est de coutume de votre
parcours de vos engagements mais aussi
quelques mots sur sur l'actualité il ya
quelques jours se tenait les
commémorations à des attentats de 2015
de janvier 2015 qui ont visé la
rédaction notamment de charlie hebdo le
magasin hyper cacher ou encore à cette
policière municipale qui étaient
installés dans les yvelines
ainsi qu'ils étaient assassinés en ans
après est ce que vous vous sentez
charlie et couture 7 cette question est
un peu brutal
je me sens charlie je me sens en
compassion avec les familles des
victimes sur tout et je me sent inquiet
sur ce qui pourrait arriver
voilà pour le futur parce qu'il ya un
élan à l'issue des attentats encore un
an après on en parle ce devenu un slogan
à une revendication de bataille je suis
charlie ça veut dire beaucoup est ce que
oui mais beaucoup et en même temps voilà
je vous l'avais dit ce qu'elle veut dire
beaucoup de choses que j'aime pas trop
me prononcer par rapport à ça je préfère
des choses plus précise que ça avez-vous
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai préféré vous
répondre différemment
il ya un sujet qui divise la classe
politique aussi actuellement c'est la
déchéance de la nationalité
quelle est votre position là dessus vous
écoutez c'est un peu ça enfin
franchement il faut le faire mais c'est
pas l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est de retrouver contrôles
aux frontières
ça c'est une évidence
fermer les mosquées salafistes les lieux
cultuels c'est réaliste et pour dire
renvoyer les imams qui ne prêche pas en
français ou qui prêchait la déchéance de
la nationalité c'est une mauvaise idée
non c'est pas une mauvaise idée mais
c'est une petite idée qu on va dire
voilà c est nécessaire en une semaine
manière mais n'est pas suffisante
on va poursuivre la discussion en salle
cette fois ci je vous laisse je vais
l'annoncer par la sema 15
film chevrier lui du front national ou
peut-être bientôt d'une nouvelle
formation parce que le front national
pourrait changer de nom il ya un bureau
politique à la fin à la fin du mois il
s'agira de poser les bases pour 2017
pour la présidentielle notamment kolo
vous êtes favorable au changement de
logement non écoutés admettons que j'aie
une boîte qui passe de 10 % de parts de
marché à 40%
est-ce que je vais changer le nom pour
vous c'est pas pertinent alors voir pour
vous c'est pas perdre vous avez trouvé
tout seul ça se fera dans la douleur
malgré tout si un changement de nom
parce que il ya des partisans du
changement et puis il ya les partisans
justement du fait de rester sur les
bases qui avait été édictée par jean
marie le pen jean-marie le pen qui a
d'ailleurs dit que si le parti changer
de nom lui le récupérerai ce nom c'est
vrai une scission au sein du front
national est ce que c'est possible ou
pas vrai c'est une autre affaire en tout
cas ça sera dans la douleur si jamais ça
se fait là aussi c'est un argument qui
va à l'encontre du rail en débat un
débat sérieux
il ya aujourd'hui encore maintenant que
jean marie le pen a quitté le front
national plutôt plutôt de force que
degré il ya encore un débat entre les
plus anciens les nouveaux militants les
nouveaux élus les anciens élus oui parce
que
c'est des vrais questions de tension
aujourd'hui fidèle de jean-marie le pen
pour la plupart sont restés mouvement y
en a certains qui ont rendu leur carte
mais relativement peu finalement donc
ils sont
il n'y avait pas de monnaie d'échangé il
y aurait pu y avoir dans l'est de change
c'est jean marie le pen s'était présenté
au parc avait créé un mouvement etc
il aurait pu entraîner si j'en avais eu
ne l'ayant pas fait les gens sont restés
mais ça entraîne des difficultés au sein
de la formation aujourd'hui nous sommes
de faire une trempe des débats c'est une
façon polie de dire qu'il ya des
discussions agitées juteux non c'est
beaucoup dire mais bon voilà on regarde
une discussion franche et là il va y
avoir un colloque où le sujet va être
mis sur la table
jean-marie le pen vous l'avez rencontrée
il ya plus de vingt ans c'était par
l'intermédiaire de votre épouse qui est
vice présidente du front national et et
vous disiez la première conversation
avec jean marie le pen elle a été
franche et et viril c'est bien ça ça
fait genre parce que vous avez passé
quelques années au parti socialiste
auparavant oui et non non en quelques
semaines quelques semaines quelques mois
quelques semaines bon jeu j'avais
auparavant toujours eu le désir et le
coeur à gauche moi
parcours ce que j'ai toujours un peu des
censeurs de l'orphelin donc voilà et
donc je me semblait que le parti
socialiste normalement devait être le
vecteur de tout ça non et donc j'ai
adhéré
et puis je me suis vite aperçu que de
l'erreur que je faisais puisque il m'est
apparu très vite que on pouvait pas
faire de social en ouvrant les
frontières économiques je parle des
frontières économiques c'est à dire de
laisser entrer des biens et des services
fabriqués à l'autre bout du monde par
des gens qui acceptent des salaires à un
dollar par jour donc et y en a des
milliards de gens qui sont prêts à
travailler à ce prix là et avec une
qualité de travail d'ailleurs qui
parfois peut être supérieure à celle
qu'on peut trouver chez nous donc ça
paraissait totalement aberrant
sauf accès parce que nous acceptions les
salaires comparables ce qui me paraît
fou enfin - le coût de transport et
s'est dégradée sur ensemble et non mais
donc la logique a été débouté le parti
socialiste pour partir au front national
ailleurs et avec l'histoire de l'euro
aussi parce que à ce moment là le parti
socialiste est très pro euros
et moi ça me paraît aberrant parce que
de se priver de cette possibilité
d'ajuster sa propre monnaie par rapport
à la productivité de nos propres
produits
comparé aux autres ça me paraissait se
retire ce tir et se tirer une balle dans
le pied quoi certaine manière après donc
je rencontre comme vous l'avez dit
fortuitement
jean marie le pen évidemment eux
j'avais beaucoup de réticences
et je vais poser les questions franches
sur l'antisémitisme la xénophobie sur un
tas de choses et alors c'est vrai pour
aussi et c est sa réponse a été
absolument de l'éclair s'est montré
clair et convaincant
donc du coup et en même temps bon il
répondait à un souci concernant l'euro
et loué le lou gehrig frontières donc
voilà j'ai j'ai adhéré tout à fait
normalement et puis progressivement
j'étais responsable de circonscription
du côté de rambouillet depuis mai après
départementale on parle des différentes
formations politiques aujourd'hui encore
vous ne vous considérez ni de droite et
encore moins d'extrême droite c'est bien
ça pas prêts du tout déçu alors ça veut
dire quoi être d'extrême droite avait
j'attendais que vous me disiez mais je
pense que c'est sont des gens sont des
gens qui veulent prendre le pouvoir par
la force et ça puisque je comprends et
qui n'ont pas l'intention de le rendre
une fois de plus montré les corps voilà
c'est pas du tout le cas et puis non il
faudrait aussi être à 6 des 9 ce qu'il
faut dit pas qu'il n'y a pas de racistes
et xénophobes dominé au sein du front
national ce serait mentir de nous mais
je dis je pense qu'il y en a aussi dans
les autres partis alors bon c'était
qualifie pas le parti ce qu'ils
qualifient partie cesson c'est son
discours c'est son programme moi et moi
je me dis tiens pas de racistes ya pas
des xénophobes ou front national enfin
il y en a mais en tout cas c'est pas là
c'est parce que parce qu'il représente
le front national mais malgré tout
comment vous gérez par exemple ce genre
de situation qu'on les gens qui veulent
vous rejoindre front national parce
qu'ils ont des idées exemples de ce
genre
voilà ils prennent la portent humilié en
tout cas dans ces quatre fédérations
genre de votre fédération et puis la
chance de pouvoir la construire
complètement donc ce sont des gens qui
sont à mon image
dans tout le faisant 18 donc je vois là
appel choses pas évidemment jamais
équivalent on parlait du parti
socialiste 8 janvier 96 c'est la date de
la disparition de françois mitterrand
cela fait 20 ans adorent regarder quelle
image de françois mitterrand parce que
les sympathisants du front national ont
plutôt une nostalgie pour françois
mitterrand et un sondage qui a été
publié au début du mois de janvier cinq
points 55% des sympathisants du front
national qui sont nostalgiques de
françois mitterrand et vous mettez en
fait partie non je suis pas du tout net
je suis nostalgique de 80 mais pas de 83
et puisque langue de l'élan de 90 que ça
va apporter à un élan formidable bond et
puis en 83 non il a fallu resserrer
davis resserrer le crédit et cetera si
vous souvenez faire faire descendre
l'inflation
ça a été des choses assez dramatique que
ce dernier
mais pour la raison que vous a expliqué
c'est à dire que il a distribué
de la monnaie ainsi je puis dire un peu
facilement et en même temps il ouvert
les frontières
donc évidemment la balance extérieure
s'est détérioré les équilibres
financiers sont détériorées et il a
fallu serrer très fort
donc c est à partir de ce moment là où
j'étais totalement convaincu qu'on
pouvait pas faire les deux mais françois
mitterrand qui a permis au front
national d'exister et de se développer
cela permet oui enfin comme comme
d'autres une succession d'erreurs croix
de la part de nos dirigeants qui ont
permis qu'un parti comme le front
national c'est pas que ça qui a fait que
le front national
non mais on dit aussi que françois
mitterrand le parti socialiste joue un
petit peu avec cette idée du front
national pour les gens me remettais la
droite a besoin de gens mutilés sont
jamais sentis comme ça c'est possible
votre engagement au front national
remonte à plus de vingt ans aujourd'hui
l'image du front national malgré tout
évolué dans l'opinion publique les
résultats ne sont pas les mêmes
aujourd'hui comment vous avez vécu cette
évolution et les premières années au
front national où les choses étaient
plus compliquées pour vous balleux
difficilement quand c'était plus
compliqué j'ai jamais eu trop de
problèmes dans ma cour
il faut être honnête pour leurs dehors
des gens qui étaient bons viscéralement
opposé au front national et qui évitait
de me serrer la main
non parce que adhérer la démarche
n'était pas la même même pour un poids
militants et sympathisants adhérer au
front national
il ya vingt ans ça ne signifie pas la
même chose qu'aujourd'hui c'était pas
aussi facile n'est pas obtus voilà dans
les mentalités
maintenant est ce que véritablement on
est arrivé au bout de la dédiabolisation
ya un peu de ça dans votre question
vernon n'ont d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé
là entre les deux tours de l'élection
régionale a prouvé que non parce que tu
encore quelqu'un comme le premier
ministre accuse ce parti est un parti
raciste qui rit la ferrari la fed entre
les deux tours mais on peut quand même
se poser la question d'ailleurs
seulement
la possibilité pour un premier ministre
de faire ça
franchement ça paraît quand même sur le
pré ya eu des pratiques avons parlé de
jean marie le pen tout à l'heure il ya
eu des condamnations aussi à l'encontre
de jean-marie le pen dans certaines de
ses déclarations mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est que ces
déclarations de manuel valls ont porté
et si elles ont porté
c'est que quelque part il ya encore
quelque chose qui dit dans le
subconscient des français attention
sinon ça n'aurait pas marché et vraiment
on voit que ça alors bon l'audit des
condamnations mais ses déclarations sur
comment dire sur son opinion sinon un
alors cette opinion maintenant on est
plus conforme à la loi telle qu'elle
existe apparemment puisque les juges en
ont jugé ainsi si je puis dire
on peut en discuter longuement voilà on
va venir faire des bannis refaire
l'histoire d'ailleurs on va marquer
juste une pause je vous propose
d'écouter un micro trottoir nous sommes
allés rencontrer les habitants du
département des habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines pour leur demander s
ils le font national avait changé
justement depuis sa création pense que à
une meilleure vision que celle de que le
fondateur qui y massacrer un petit peu
toutes les personnes des alentours
là il ya beaucoup plus une ouverture
d'esprit qui est beaucoup plus grande
et oui il a évolué comme doc et de
quelle manière
non peut-être plus modérée danse
toujours la même chose mais le dit plus
le dit autrement parce qu'il ya toujours
des mêmes idées bien arrêtées est clair
ça jamais changé moi ça fait je connais
le père heyman soit c'est juste il donne
face à citou toujours les mêmes les
migrations l'euro tout ça c'est la fonte
commerce
c'était dans le sens où il a changé de
physique mais au niveau des idées ce
n'est même alors en même temps c'est la
saisie dans la nomenclature halle du fn
qu'à changer si on veut dire comme ça
mais les gens de base n'ont pas changé
ça reprend un petit peu ce qu'on me
disait tout allait absolument escales
des changements alors concrètement dans
le fond au-delà des déclarations et des
sentiments de chacun et c'est qui est au
parti depuis une vingtaine d'années dans
discours pas tellement
mais il y a des choses qu'on met plus en
avant qu'à voir par exemple la politique
économique qui n'était pas trop mise en
avant du temps de jean marais et qui
maintenant est quand même beaucoup plus
ouvertement discutée à d'ailleurs pas
paraissait d'ailleurs un autre critère
me remettrai qui est plus de débat
autour de l'euro et c'est donc mais on
sent que c'est un socket cette question
est un peu tabou bon mais on
souhaiterait au contraire entrer dans ce
débat
avoir la possibilité d'expliquer d'avoir
d'avoir une dire une certaine pédagogie
sur notre sueur notes pendant la
politique pour revenir à vous la
politique c'est aussi à la marge d'une
activité professionnelle ou au civil
vous êtes dans la stratégie marketing le
commercial autour des métiers du
transport aérien faire faire carrière
faire de la faire carrière en politique
faire de la politique c'est pas une fin
en soi
il voulait garder cette activité annexe
ou à écouter
moi j'ai travaillé pendant 40 ans fut
décoré de la médaille grand or
je suis très fier
voilà il n'y a pas d'ambition politique
non non personnel j'entends si vous avez
des convictions il est assez naturel que
vous aviez en politique
sinon vous êtes spectateur et vous ne
maîtrisez pas les choses mans alors on
peut on peut critiquer tel ou tel parti
mais si si on ne rentre pas dedans aussi
on ne le combat pas par un autre biais
bah
journée ont des spectateurs c'est ça
sert à rien de notre vie ne sert à rien
donc je crois qu'on est tous en somme on
essaye de construire une société
ansamble où il fait bon vivre
on est bien ensemble voilà et où on est
seul on assure la sécurité de nos
enfants quoi aussi sécurité d'emploi
dans tous les domaines la sécurité aussi
économies sur votre parcours militant
ensuite secrétaire de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines celle de
rambouillet puis secrétaire
départementale des yvelines depuis
maintenant huit ans vous avez mené de
nombreuses campagnes locales
il n'y a pas eu de victoire ce qu'on m'a
dit d'ailleurs en introduction de
l'émission puisque vous êtes souvent
dans l'opposition mais une victoire et
pourtant il ya un maire front national
dans les yvelines dorénavant syrie
notamment que la ville l'a emporté en
mars 2014 dans une certaine surprise
vous êtes dit quoi à ce moment là
j'aurais dû aller me présenter là bas
pour enfin l'emporter pour encore très
content que ce soit cyril d'ailleurs
parce que vous avez en tire pour si on
se met lui qui vient d'arriver
c'est un jeune mère vous ai dit moi je
suis là depuis vingt ans et j'ai pas
gagné d lui arriver ils l'emportent j'ai
pris du tice ce sentiment là d'abord il
est plus jeune que moi c'est normal que
vont ils arrivent non j'étais très très
content pour lui
ils sont l'équipe et depuis lors je suis
content de ne pas m'être trompé parce
que voilà il a il a bien progressé
on voit on a vu dans
dernières élections et pas tellement la
régionale mais les départementales et
européennes que les bois du front
national à mantes la ville avait
beaucoup progressé
ce qui m'a fait lire des livres à un
moment que aujourd'hui on peut dire que
le parti socialiste définitivement perdu
mon plaisir
pourtant il ya division d'ailleurs je
vois d'ailleurs mais le maire de
mantes-la-jolie l'ami pierre bédier
l'orgue sur l'année avec avidité joie
qui l'art il a créé une permanence donc
ils espèrent malheureusement elle est la
plupart du temps elle est fermée ce
permanence mais bon ça reste entre nous
personnellement dans les prochaines
années vous vous voyez où toujours à la
recherche d'un mandat d'une victoire
dans le département écoutez je suis très
heureux d'animer une équipe dans le 78
franchement donc et c'est une équipe
très sympathique et j'espère que ça
continuera aussi longtemps que ça et que
ça restera sympathique
voilà c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est une
aventure humaine mais pas avec une
victoire nécessairement bon pas
nécessaire par évidemment servir je vais
pas leur fusée c'est évident mais vous
pourriez aller chercher parce que quelle
que soit la formation politique au fonds
national comme ailleurs il ya aussi
quelquefois des parachutages pourparlers
grossièrement oui dans des
circonscriptions
je ne fais pas adhérer le plus ou moins
facilement dans votre version je ne
cherche pas ça m'intéresse pas et de
toute façon si j'avais un poste ce
serait pour faire quelque chose ce
serait pas pour avoir le poste
bayer pourra voir dans quels domaines
justement celui de l'économie puisque
c'est au civil on parlait tout à l'heure
avoir une action sur l'économie c'est
évident je suis absolument convaincu
qu'il faut revenir en revenir à une
monnaie nationale recontrôler nos
frontières sur le économique ça c'est
fondamental
sinon on s'en sortira pas sinon on sera
obligé de bloquer les salaires de
bloquer les pensions éventuellement de
les réduire
on pourra avoir même des faillites
bancaires bientôt on pourra voir des
gens qui perdent leur épargne pour avoir
des catastrophes
je dirais que c'est un scénario pour lui
pour faire peur aussi
non mais aujourd'hui regardez on a on a
une dette colossale étaient équivalentes
avec allah allah vous pib un bond dans
les autres pays européens
cette dette a plutôt tendance à diminuer
et y compris la grèce y compris la grève
chez nous elle ne fait qu'augmenter et
on va très probablement très rapidement
ce qui sépare en 2016 monsieur sera
probablement en 2016 devenir le dernier
de la classe dans ce domaine d'ailleurs
le ratio entre la dette et la recherche
ça sera le plus mauvais de toute
l'europe
là en 2016 qu'est ce qui va se passer
les marchés monétaires vont regarder ça
pour l'instant ils sont pas trop méchant
avec la france parce que telle et
accoudée à l'allemagne la france est mal
classée elle a toujours on sait qu'il ya
de l'épars bon mais afin trop c'est trop
quoi y'a un moment quand vous êtes le
dernier de la classe ça se voit et il
est pas impossible qu à ce moment là les
taux d'intérêt augmentent et les pas
impossible qu'un certain nombre de
banques et des musiques et des
difficultés et je dis pas ça poids pour
faire peur je dis simplement c'est la
réalité il faut la regarder en face il
faut traiter le problème
et voilà c'est pour ça que je suis
engagé très fortement dans ce sens là je
veux pas voir ça pas d'élection en 2016
les prochaines élections 2010 cette
présidentielle législatives on va faire
de la politique fiction qu'elle quelles
priorités pour marine le pen en cas de
victoire là aussi nous avons posé la
question écouté ma priorité je pense de
rendre de nouveau
aux français sa légitimité je veux dire
par là redonner du poids aux valeurs
françaises et qui sont un petit peu
oublié pas de nos jours je pense sur
l'immigration ne sais pas je ne connais
pas vraiment son programme je ne sais
même pas ces lendemains migration je
pense avant tout après fermé les portes
de la france je pense pas c'est pas si
facile que ça mais vraiment une
immigration et l'économie sait pas non
plus si elle a vraiment un bon plan
économique
j'ai pas du tout la changera rien du
tout la première des choses avancent à
l'aide avant ses proches comme on le
fait la sortie de l'union européenne
mais bon ça je sais pas je pense que fin
c'est pas si facile à faire donc voilà
c'est une idée mais je sais pas si elle
y arrivera fin une première décision que
vous attendez pour 2017 en cas de
victoire de marine le pen sort du bureau
la sortie de l'euro
malgré tout je vois bien que c'est pas
tout à fait ce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui
asie
on va d'abord renégocier les traités si
les traités
sur n'arrive pas à les renier constr
référendum
et après seulement on sortira du lot
j'ai peur que ces étapes successives
alerte les marchés financiers comme je
leur ai
que les choses se passent par un peu un
peu
star de ce qui se passait là j'en passe
donc ça veut dire quoi que mais mieux il
vaudrait mieux mon avis y aller assez
rapidement d'ailleurs à faire un
référendum proposé de refaire mais y
aller assez rapidement je suis pas
contre le fait d'essayer de négocier
décrété au palace mais le faire très
vite efface 2006 mon argent c'est un peu
m un peu le couteau sous la gorge et
nono
partenaires on quitte la politique pour
une dernière une rade dernière réaction
ensuite la politique quoique je vous
laisse écouter ces quelques notes de
musique david bowie il ya quelques jour
disparaissait david bowie il ya eu des
hommages dans le monde entier les
hommages d'anonymes de célébrités de
politique également
il n'est pas du côté du front national
d'ailleurs on entend assez rarement le
front national les élus du front
national se prononcer lors de
disparitions d'artistes pourquoi tout
simplement pour être demandée au fond de
moi je sais pas
écoutez moi c'est une musique qui me
plaisait beaucoup la musique de ma
jeunesse quoi donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce regret
est évidemment d'un disparu d'abord on
revêt toujours une disparition c'est un
peu un peu classique de dire ça à quoi
donc mais particulièrement où il
représentait aussi beaucoup l'évolution
de la société il est jeune aurait été la
politique mais pas tant que ça parce
qu'il ya eu aussi des bouleversements
l'allemagne qui est remercié par exemple
david bowie pour l'avoir aidé à faire
tomber le mur
voilà juste ça donc ça des répercussions
aussi et donc votre sentiment c'était
quoi 2 par rapport à david bowie par
rapport à cet artiste a coûté
moi c'est non
c'est une disparition
très regrettable d'autant qu'il a il
avait fait je crois un album récemment
en bon donc
et sur le plan des idées je ne connais
pas les usines monsieur david bowie et
vous appréciez sa musique a beaucoup
merci philippe chevrier conseiller
régional front national en ile-de-france
la fia va vous
dieu